this video is sponsored by skillshare
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skincare nerd and pigment producing
machine i am super prone to pigmentation it
runs in my family here is a photo of my dad
unfortunately i inherited these genes my sister
did not so i took one for the team here
i've talked about visible light and blue light
and their effects on pigmentation in lots
of detail before i'll link those videos in
the description but there's been more studies
done since then fortunately my conclusions
are still correct in short the vast majority
of us don't have to worry about visible light
or blue light coming from our screens there
just isn't enough light coming from them but
if your skin is darker and more prone to pigmentation
you might have to worry about visible light
coming from the sun visible light from the
sun in particular short wavelength high energy
blue light can make pigment problems worse
the main ones are melasma and post-inflammatory
hyperpigmentation so this is stuff like the
dark marks that you get left on your skin
after acne so today i'm going to give an update
of what we found out about protecting your
skin from visible light and you might actually
be doing it already if you like nerding out
about the science behind beauty products click
the like the subscribe and the nerdification
bell so you don't miss any videos
one topic that wasn't very well fleshed out
when i made my first video was how does blue
light actually cause pigmentation it's still
not super well researched but it looks like
it's mostly to do with a protein in your skin
that senses light a photoreceptor called opsin-3
once opsin-3 is triggered by enough blue light
it sends a signal to your skin the melanocytes
in your skin these are the pigment producing
cells to produce more pigment it might also
have something to do with oxidation and free
radicals but this seems to be less important
so there are some studies that have found
that some antioxidants can seem to help with
reducing how much pigment you produce after
exposure to blue light but most of the focus
is now on preventing that blue light from
getting to your skin in the first place basically
it's on making products that work like sunscreen
but for blue light
so which products will actually protect your
skin against blue light earlier research found
that regular sunscreens like the ones that
go on your skin and either go transparent
or they look maybe a little bit white actually
aren't that good at protecting against visible
light even if you have a thick white layer
of mineral or physical sunscreen it still
doesn't work very well but some of the earlier
studies found that tinted physical sunscreens
gave pretty good protection physical or mineral
sunscreens are the ones that contain zinc
oxide and or titanium dioxide the tint is
from iron oxides there are three iron oxides
that are used to make products look skin colored
these are in things like foundations and tinted
sunscreens these are red yellow and black
and they're added in different amounts and
different ratios to get the different shades
of skin a lot of the time they're listed in
the ingredients list as their color index
number their ci number i've listed them here
and all the iron oxides absorb a bit of blue
light which is how they protect against blue
light so that's why you've probably heard
a lot about tinted physical sunscreens and
blue light protection at this point you might
be a little bit confused because if you've
watched my videos before you'll know that
physical and chemical sunscreens mostly work
the same way they mostly absorb uv and turn
it into a small amount of heat and they also
scatter and reflect a tiny bit but that amount
is really tiny so why is everyone focusing
on mineral and physical sunscreens here's
where it gets a little bit complicated it's
to do with titanium dioxide titanium dioxide
is one of the active ingredients in mineral
sunscreens it's really good at protecting
against uv it also tends to be the ingredient
that gives the worst white cast one way of
getting rid of this white cast is by chopping
up the titanium dioxide into smaller particles
these are usually nano sized particles this
makes the titanium dioxide scatter and reflect
a lot less visible light and so you get less
of that white look and it also actually increases
uv absorption so it actually works as a better
sunscreen filter but on the flip side it tends
to make it worse at visible light protection
but when you have bigger particles of titanium
dioxide so this is 200 300 nanometers this
tends to give really bad white cast because
it scatters and reflects so much white light
these bigger particles are also worse at uv
protection so they're not really used in sunscreens
although sometimes they do form by accident
because if you have uncoated titanium dioxide
it tends to clump together and form these
bigger particles anyway and that tends to
bring down the spf protection and give unnecessary
white cast but this scattering of visible
light that's so annoying in sunscreens is
actually pretty useful for visible light protection
scattering means that the path of the light
gets changed and so instead of taking a straight
line through the sunscreen film it'll actually
bounce around in the film for a bit longer
it takes a longer path and if you have iron
oxides in there as well then that means there's
a higher chance of it hitting some iron oxide
and getting absorbed before it gets to your
skin these larger particles are called pigmentary
titanium dioxide and as you expect from the
name they're used in pigments they're not
used as sunscreens it's the main color ingredient
in things like white eyeshadow and white eyeliner
but you actually find it in lots of other
makeup products as well a white color is really
good at covering stuff up it's really opaque
it's used in foundations and tinted sunscreens
to give them coverage and in fact you actually
usually find more titanium dioxide in these
products than you find iron oxides it's like
how if you have a dark thing and you want
to paint it a light color you usually cover
it up with white first and then paint the
light color paint on top so if you see a tinted
sunscreen and it has titanium dioxide in it
it doesn't necessarily mean that it is a physical
sunscreen if it has these larger particles
of pigmentary titanium dioxide in it then
that titanium dioxide isn't helping with the
uv protection the sunscreen part but it is
helping with the tinted part that means that
the sunscreen part isn't actually that important
i mean it is important it's super important
for protecting your skin against uv and uv
is more strongly linked to pigment and other
changes in your skin than visible light is
but when we're talking about visible light
it's that combination of pigmentary titanium
dioxide and iron oxides that's doing the protecting
work
based on that we'd expect tinted chemical
sunscreens to protect against visible light
as well and yes they do in a study from brazil
the researchers looked at 41 different tinted
sunscreens they measured how much blue violet
light went through a layer that was 2 milligrams
per square centimeter thick the standard amount
for a sunscreen they found that 26 of these
sunscreens which is almost two-thirds of them
blocked over 99.9% of the visible light and
this included both chemical and physical sunscreens
in the same study they also tested three non-tinted
sunscreens and they found that they didn't
protect against visible light much at all
and so based on that mechanism foundations
also protect against visible light and in
fact in a couple of studies it was actually
foundation-like products with high coverage
that gave better visible light protection
than tinted sunscreens this isn't too surprising
because a more opaque product will have more
pigmentary titanium dioxide and more iron
oxides in one study they found that a foundation
with spf 35 gave better visible light protection
than a tinted sunscreen with higher spf protection
in another study they found that visible light
protection wasn't correlated with spf so a
higher spf product isn't necessary to protect
you from visible light
then why are so many of these visible light
studies on tinted sunscreens rather than on
foundations i think that it's just because
a tinted sunscreen is way more practical for
most people who aren't skin care and makeup
enthusiasts like us a lot of us prefer using
two separate specialized products because
it means that you have a lot more control
over the final outcome how the final look
is tinted sunscreens only come in a few shades
and so if your skin doesn't match one of these
popular colors according to someone in product
development then you're not going to have
a good color match it's a lot easier to get
a good color match if you use a foundation
there's also the fact that most of these studies
tested the product at two milligrams per square
centimeter this is a pretty unrealistic amount
for most tinted products it can make you look
like you've got face paint on so if you're
only relying on a tinted sunscreen and that
tinted sunscreen has too much tint to apply
the proper amount then you're going to have
less uva uvb and visible light protection
but if you have a separate sunscreen as well
something that you can apply a lot of then
at least you're not missing out on that uv
protection but you can imagine how hard it
would be for a dermatologist to convince someone
who isn't using either sunscreen or makeup
to suddenly start using both it's much easier
to convince them to start using a single product
and this is the direction that most companies
seem to be heading in hopefully the extra
focus on tinted sunscreens means that they'll
start making more shades and the fact that
visible light affects people with darker skin
more hopefully means that they'll put more
effort into making darker shades that actually
match darker skin this isn't really something
the beauty industry has been really good at
so far so i'm not sure how optimistic i should
be so in short if you want to prevent pigment
from the sun your best bet is high uva protection
and a tinted product with heavy coverage that
can be a sunscreen and a separate concealer
or foundation or a tinted sunscreen that goes
on well
and like with uv there are other ways to avoid
visible light exposure that's not just sunscreens
and if you use them with sunscreens it tends
to work better so i'm talking about things
like staying in the shade during the middle
of the day when it's the sunniest and using
things like hats and clothing to protect your
skin i hope you liked this video if you did
click the like the subscribe also leave me
a comment letting me know what else you want
me to talk about you can follow me on instagram
tiktok and check out my blog as well
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this video
and for allowing me to make super nerdy deep
dives into pretty much anything i want which
is honestly so nice of them skillshare is
an online community that has thousands of
classes on lots of topics like design photography
web development marketing and analytics most
of the classes are less than an hour so it's
really achievable to learn something new even
with a tight schedule i recently became obsessed
with houseplants i know this is peak pandemic
millennial and yes i also got a tool recently
that lets me make smashed avocado on toast
really efficiently anyway it turns out skillshare
has a whole bunch of classes on how to look
after house plants i went to an agricultural
high school so i thought i knew a lot about
plants but it turns out that knowing how to
grow 200 acres of radishes isn't really the
same as keeping a house plant alive i learned
a lot from chris satch who is a botanist his
class is called happy house plants caring
for your plants apparently you're meant to
throw out dead leaves and not just let them
drop into the pot and rot and do the whole
circle of life thing the rotting leaves can
actually attract pests and cause disease so
now i can stop feeling bad about micromanaging
how my plants look i'm not being a shallow
stage mum i am helping if you want to check
out skillshare the first thousand people to
click the link will get a free trial of skillshare
premium it's normally less than $10 a month
with a yearly subscription thanks for watching